so everyone is excited that Shazam is
back so was it fun to kind of get in
superhero mode oh absolutely yeah I mean
it's such an incredible gift of a job
like ever since I was a little kid I
dreamed about being an actor and I get
to do that and that just blows my mind
still and I also always dreamed about
being a superhero I think we all do when
we're kids and I never really let go of
that uh so so but the cool thing is like
I love Tom Hanks in big and I love
Christopher Reeves and Superman and I
get to play like the love child of that
boat what a great yeah it really is a
big Superman and it's so fun and I just
get to tap into my inner child that I
never really grew out of on a daily
basis and just bring that to life and
the fact that I got to do that once was
already incredible now I get to do it
again and we get to bring the whole
family the whole shazamly back together
all the rest of the cast I love the
sharing of the I'm not running it watch
the first one spoiler alert but like you
shared the powers I think that that's
such a great lesson yeah it's like it's
such a great message overall and also in
this new one you get to body slam Helen
yeah I get to suplex a Dame into
concrete
um it's a big fight it's so it's so dope
this scene that scene right there is so
fun that was the first thing we got to
work together on it was like three pages
of us just having dialogue and I was so
like what am I doing this is Dame Helen
Mirren right now and she's right after
that so everything goes and then
everything goes Super South yeah go
super South but she's the coolest she
honestly I think she yeah she she's
she's the undameest Dame she doesn't
throw it around she's just like she's
just like a really chill like human who
wants to roll up her sleeves and jump in
the sandbox and have fun and that's the
kind of actor you want to work with
always yeah yeah yeah and she's an icon
on top I already loved her but now I
love her more from that knowledge and
she this fight is incredible yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]